fine since you guys are expecting to do
another one
when you're as Fabulous As Kylie Jenner
being high maintenance is just part of
the gig I love it that's just one little
secret the billionaire makeup Mogul and
reality star is fasten up to thanks to
tick tock's my red flags filter which
forces users to face their flaws or at
least what flaws the algorithm invents
for them so scary and Kylie has no
problem admitting to hers let's see
[Music]
no no
sometimes let's try this again
[Music]
let's watch real
it's fun
[Music]
that's true enough litterer okay I feel
like this one is gonna be the one
mm-hmm
[Music]
yeah we know that one's a red flag fail
Kylie and her big sisters are the queens
of selfies it's fun but social media is
all about the videos these days and
Kylie's keeping us fed with plenty of
tick tock content including an impromptu
house tour I'm in my bar right now and I
like it because it has this pretty light
and this is my bar room
this is my living room
this is weird she's actually been in a
sharing mood all week inviting followers
inside her purse too this is like a
really honest what's in my bag because I
have not
clean this bag or gone through this at
all there's like a lot of mirror
I have stormy's little watch in here it
was actually my watch but she wore it
look how small her wrist is she wore it
to a birthday party and shouldn't want
to wear it anymore yeah that play watch
is actually a Rolex average price
between seven and twelve thousand
dollars but anyway I have
the skims hair clip always need a hair
clip
always I'm having so much fun glue tape
because who doesn't need glue tape but
if you didn't know something about me I
like to scrapbook
so if you like to scrapbook you need
glue tape
tampon
Coachella wristband
is this the craziest what's in my back
that was fun
foreign